rien n'a filtré avant les annonces des
manuels macron ce soir dans gabriel atta
le porte parole du gouvernement a tenu
un point presse
extrêmement rapide il expliquait que la
dégradation massive général et
inattendue selon lui un de la situation
impliqué d'entrer dans une nouvelle
étape
alors vous le disais c'est le second
conseil de défense en 24 heures mais il
faut dire aussi que les mesures qui ont
été prises par emmanuel macron
interviennent après consultation hier
soir des partis politiques et des
partenaires sociaux
je vous propose d'écouter et gabriela
talent nous avons mis en oeuvre de
nombreuses mesures pour ralentir cette
seconde vague par nos efforts collectifs
à tous et par des mesures qui ont été
décidées par le gouvernement mais comme
partout en europe elles nous touchent
aujourd'hui très fortement et nous
devons tout faire pour qu'elle ne nous
submerge pas c'est le sens de
l'intervention du président de la
république qui s'exprimera ce soir et
qui annoncera ce soir une nouvelle étape
qui a été décidé ce matin en conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale à cette
crise sanitaire nous savons en porte
aussi une crise économique et sociale
ce sont les deux faces d'une même pièce
ce qui oppose crise sanitaire et crise
économique et sociale ont tort nous ne
réglerons pas la crise économique sans
maîtriser la crise sanitaire nous ne
réglerons pas la crise économique en
feignant d'ignorer son impact de
l'épidémie sur les vies humaines et sur
nos hôpitaux
d'autres sujets ont été abordés lors de
ce point presse rapide comme la menace
terroriste nourrie par des appels à la
haine à l'étranger
kbl attal a rappelé les efforts contre
l'islamisme par exemple la dissolution à
d'associations qui est prévu dans le
projet de loi contre le séparatisme
islamistes et dans ce cadre il a
expliqué que l'association baraka city
avait été dissoute pour propos
antisémites menace demain et apologie de
crime contre l'humanité et toute chose
étant lié les relations tendues avec la
turquie ont été abordés l'ambassadeur de
france en turquie a été rappelé mais à
dix la gabriela talent malgré les
intimidations la france ne renoncera pas
à ses principes et ses valeurs
il a affirmé que
l'europe était solidaire de la france
face à la turquie dans cette affaire